it's 1914 and here's Belgium's tall King
Albert dressing his small nation for a
disastrous date with mighty Germany
power-crazed Kaiser Wilhelm refuses
to bypass Belgium as neutral nation not to
be believed this is Albert's answer forced
from their homeland onto alien soil Belgian
troops fight with embattled French and even
where fighting is thickest King Albert here
with baton of France comes to see his troops
here on edge of famed no-man's land on fringe
of fiercest fighting tall Albert first is first
a soldier and like a soldier he goes wherever
Belgian troops must go even into the trenches
braving skies patrolled by enemy planes and
turned into playground of death by Baron rich
Tobin and his flying circus King Albert
must have an Eagles look at progress on
the front even though the venture may mean
his death his courage inspires the world